yeah today I'm here to talk to you about
the cloud of programming and after an
Eric's perfect introduction I really
don't have to introduce myself anymore
it seems and but I've been working with
rust since early 2014 and I've been
loving every minute of it right now
I'm mostly concerned with making CLI
tools in rust really amazing and also if
you happen to be in Cologne you should
come to rally them you can find me in
the on the Internet
on these addresses and with that let's
start at the beginning the very very
beginning what is a computer program
let's think about that for a minute now
okay fine so to make a program work you
basically have to tell the computer what
to do step by step step by very tiny
step so this is imperative this is
literally called imperative programming
and if you do enough of this it's very
hard to reason about the general
behavior of your program but you might
be saying where this rust fest love
assembly camp so what are you even
talking about if you're here for
assembly this is not a talk for you I'm
so sorry
but the common theme was my talks said
I'll at some point drift off and talk
about what maintainable code looks like
and that's always having maintainable
code is in high demand but it's also
very hard to get there so the question
you need to ask yourself this is my code
maintainable and this is a good question
and I have some more questions first off
like how much do you need to read to
understand what is going on but also how
much do you need to write to make a
change in your program code and last but
not least how easy is it to identify the
core concepts of
going on these are very generic
questions I know and they apply to
basically every piece of code you've
ever written Isaac so what does it
actually have to do with this talk
because the talk is declarative
programming so let's define this and as
always when I need to find the
definition of something I go to the
Kapiti write wikipedia tells me that the
cloud of program is often defined as any
style of programming that is not in
person and that's true okay
not really helpful the Wikipedia page
goes on and talks about some examples
from the client of programming for
example HTML or regular expressions or
sequel but also has school and prologue
helpful yeah okay okay fine but what is
it really about I'd summarize it as it's
about the what instead of the how the
idea is that you don't write all the
steps on how to get somewhere but
instead to try to express what you want
to accomplish and basically if your
computer do stuff for you which is nice
and you might be wondering how okay so a
few steps you might want to take is to
identify concepts that your program is
about and you try to extract their
behavior you abstract over control flow
that means you have in your editor with
syntax highlighting less of those
colorful key words and more expressive
function names and in the end you hope
to be able to compose your application
from smaller parts okay okay fine I know
what you'll say anything get to the
point what does it actually have to do
with rust this is super abstract like
okay how do I apply this and this is
very good question because this is
actually about introducing abstractions
and if the right you end up as code
that's easier to reason about and
declarative code in rust
okay fine so as the cloud of code is
ever saying but imperative code
apparently and rust is totally able to
give you all the emotive needs you ever
need to have you might be wondering okay
if this is a functional construct and
I'm going to talk about functional
programming now and I am sad to say I'm
not because rust to me is very pragmatic
in that it has functional elements that
allows you to write very functional
looking code but it also allows you to
embrace mutability and write imperative
code if you so desire and I leave it to
the experts to say if rust is actually a
functional programming language but I
want to talk to you about how rust is
able to abstract over ideas and in fact
one of the selling points of rust is to
have a zero cost abstractions which
basically talks about the runtime cost
of having abstractions that means you
can write abstract high level code and
if you need it to be high performance
code as well you don't have to drop down
to a lower level and write it in an
imperative style instead russ tries to
give you high performance code with high
abstraction and this talk will be by
example because it's a short talk and
I've also been talking for six minutes
already and I can't possibly give you a
recipe to churn out your code into
better code at least not in this talk
and I hope to give you some examples
that inspire you so let's start with
some placing simple and that was loose
in every piece of code I've ever touched
at some point there was a loop over a
collection of items and this looks like
a good example to me let's have a list
of items I'm going with Latin here
because we are wrong and fubar is so
over and the idea is to find the first
element that ends with a character M so
we loop over our vector and we go from
the zeros item up to the last item it's
defined by the length of the vector
and if it'll happens to end with ma'am
return son and the content of sediment
otherwise return none okay this is
simply enough it's actually easy to
retain if you're used to the style it's
very very common and you wouldn't
question it but in the real world we are
gonna have some problems for example
there are new requirements that just
happens to turn up one day imagine
you're going into the office Monday
morning and your boss tells you okay
you've been doing this code it's fine
it's working but now you need to have
something that finds the five elements
that end with em so you're gonna extend
this piece of code and you add a mutable
result to it and to push items into it
and also you try to only go up to five
elements so this if is pretty much twice
the size and in the end you can return
the result okay
this is still easy to reason about it's
count that fits on its life so I'd say
it's fine you can read it and you know
what's going on but there are some
nuances for example a very important
piece is the five and less than or equal
and actually the font I chose has the
ligature for it so it's actually less
than or equal sign but into your code it
might not look like this and the five
right in the middle is basically the new
requirement but for some reason it's
right in the middle and not just visible
okay okay what's an alternative approach
yeah third of approach is to use
iterators and if you've written rust
you've probably also come across
iterators because in receiver will come
and the advantage of this snippet of
code is that the core concepts are right
there in the method names you filter for
items that end with nan you take five of
them and you collect them I now have
committed some type intentions but
this will work in the right context
actually this is faster than the nuke
we've just seen because the loop I wrote
behind and I totally forgot that after
I've already collected five elements I
can just stop and do an early return
okay stupid mistake but it's Monday
morning right I totally forgot about it
and this code just it's way slower than
I actually needed to have it see so for
the live stream he pointed out that I'm
taking six elements because I'm not able
to count but like I said Monday morning
this is a great example of how iterators
can save me because I don't have to
count you can just like take five
elements and it's good to go yeah nice
okay
okay wasn't actually expecting that good
but what what have we done in general
we've abstracted over this control flow
of looping and conditioning and
basically just create our intent on
filtering and taking five elements also
note that this is an abstraction that is
pretty pretty powerful I have omitted to
type annotations for one reason
specifically and that is I don't care
that this is a vector and I don't care
what I'm collecting into this could be
hash sense I don't mind it's super
generic actually and this makes sense if
you have a chain of iterator calls and
it's all good but it also makes sense if
you are looking for just one condition
in an iteration for example there is an
any method that you can use to just
check hey is there any element in my
list and you don't have to write a for
loop and you don't have to write a
condition in it you can just say any
because what you want is subtract
yourselves and the element it's
very very expressive okay that's it for
iterators let's look at another example
and this is about pouncing Jason because
Jason is a very simple format you could
say okay I don't have to do any
complicated things maybe I don't know so
you know there are 30 Jason and you know
it has a value type and you know if I
have a string that looks like Jason I
hope this is formatted correctly I can
get a value out of it probably and if
there is some value a that happens to be
a number I can print it okay easy enough
but next Monday arrives next
requirements arrive and actually yes
this structure actually has three fields
and we need to deal with this and of
course is rust we know we can write data
types so we write our structure called
response and say this has three fields
and so we continue to write our code as
we've been doing it for the last week
and the difference is that it got a bit
longer yeah
and it's basically all the same the only
thing that changes is this character and
then we have our response easy enough
right
but a bit boring okay this looks like
it's pretty pretty repetitive and not
specific to the actual problem we have
that is dealing with our response Russ
gives us a very neat feature and that is
procedural macros and especially derive
macros so as you may have seen in 30
code you can just say derive deserialize
and all this boilerplate codes is a
repetitive piece of code that we've just
seen gets generated and in fact this is
same as a loop also faster because there
is no value that needs to be allocated
and filled with generic jason data and
it even has better errors too okay
a bit of a pet peeve of mine this year
has been command line applications so I
couldn't go without writing or talking
about command line arguments the core
concept and so imagine you have a
program that it's named tool for some
reason because I'm bad at coming up with
project names apparently and it takes an
input file name and an output file name
and it does some weird stuff with this
file and rides it to the output cool
that's easy using the standard library
you can just say stood and arcs and I
get an iterator over my command
arguments the first one I choose is
wrong I just realized the first one is
actually the name tool but never mind
the first one in this case in this very
specific case we're on step and works
differently is the input and the next
one is the output cool you may have seen
this pattern and that I'm now going to
tell you that there are new requirements
and two requirement is that this is not
how command-line tools should work they
should also take flags like - Oh to
specify the output file but don't worry
there's a crate for that it's called get
out and it allows you to write some easy
enough code so you can specify an opt
opt whatever that is not an option I
don't know but it's on opt and it's
called oh and it sets the output
filename this is from the documentation
I'm not kidding
and it's ok it works for this specific
case and it's not that much code at ISA
bit versus crying but it's it's ok you
can do this so we may have to ask
ourselves how much do you need to read
it's ok how much you need to write to
make a change
actually this right get-ups has nice
abstraction you can write many of those
up tops and
uh popped thingies and you can basically
build up your command line to it but how
easy is it to reason about what's
actually happening there
I don't know it's a bit it's not very
expressive but okay let's look at the
NASA crate that also implements an
abstraction over command line arguments
which is called clap and you may have
heard of it it gives you the possibility
to write down what your application
should look like basically it's there is
a type code app there's a type called
arc and you can compose an app with
arguments this also includes
documentation and it's very very
expressive because all this methods
allow you to express precisely what you
want your application to look like very
nice if you run this with - - help you
get a nice help message if you run it
with - - version to get a version number
this is abstracted away for you because
it's always assignment you don't have to
write this code by yourself but this too
has one bit of an issue and that is
similar to our days in case before now
we are looking at some values of our
arguments and we're going to deal with
the data inside and we have to do this
by ourselves interesting maybe we can do
something similar - well so did it and
yeah we can because isn't commander
arguments just to take the structure -
in fact those library called struct up
which you may have also heard of and it
allows you to describe your command-line
arguments as a structure and derive
basically all the code we've seen before
including using the documents for health
messages okay okay I've talked quite a
lot about procedural macros and Tiras
macros but I also want to touch on
subject because this is not to talk
about macros even though it may seem
like it this is a talk about abstraction
and this requires me to use the
scary-looking headline I guess and to
make this crescendo of increasing
complexity in examples usable and what
I'm trying to get at is we write generic
functions and our generic functions can
use concrete types to declare once these
are walls a very nice example I've
recently rediscovered so to say is in
web frameworks I know there are many web
frameworks also for rust but let's
imagine there is a very very generic one
and a very simple one not generic in the
scans and it's a framework where you
specify a function that takes a request
and returns a response simply enough and
our request happens to contain a body of
JSON data and we want to get a name
filled out this looks like basically the
same code we've seen in the earlier
example except if you also choosing the
name nobody if there is nobody okay so
this is actually already quite good but
you might be wondering if we've
previously managed to get rid of this
rising value may we can get rid of it in
this case too and actually we can go one
step further because C Rica's body
doesn't have to be chosen for metal at
all and that we are taking the Rica's
body and dealing with it as if it were
jason is something that we spent two
lines about and actually maybe also a
third line but we don't have to because
our generic function
could not only take a request but maybe
also some other type that tells us what
we actually want from our request and
the idea is that this Jason type here is
a type that implements for example a
trait called from request and when our
framework calls it it gives it a request
and the type size okay this request I'm
gonna powers of Jason and the login data
type defines what kind of structure we
wants is jason to power center this
allows you to express what data you want
extracted from the request without
having to do it yourself
and this also composes quite nicely
because you can say I now have it type
that is Jason or from data or I can have
it typed it's actually a couple of a
query string and jason powered and maybe
also the path of the URL this is
something we should use more often this
is it for examples but there's one more
quite important topic I want to touch on
and that is please be aware of the magic
bj of your code base and it turns out
that and sufficiently high abstraction
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
yeah and the next slide
oh I'm not going to touch on that so
sorry let let's talk about what magic is
actually in the scientific sense of
course and that's different magic as
code whose behavior is hard to predict
or to remember because at least I am
very forgetful like if you show me code
and say I have written this like half a
year ago I will have no idea what this
is about
so maybe it's also a good idea to write
code that is so expressive that you
don't have to remember it to make sense
okay so what code could be hard to
predict and familiar macros obviously
people are a lot of people actually very
fearful of using macros because they are
magic this is a quote also very generic
code and there are programming language
that say okay it's a good idea to have
generics but actually not in our use
case and there's a very very solid
argument because if you want to have
correctable code that is easy to read
that may not be as concise as you want
it to be but that is easy to understand
generics will probably know this but
also like we've all been there like we
have tried to write clever code but
could you understand so clever code
afterwards this is also magic and you
can tell magic into science if you have
to write to it for example something
like Iago expand will give you the
output of what rust C will actually
compile if it has expanded all your
macros so for example this struct of
example I gave you can paste it into
your editor run cargo expand and see how
it generates CLEP code underneath codes
that you didn't have to write but codes
that will be there and code that you can
read if you want to
sadly even the best tools will only move
this complexity towards using the tool
but not actually resolvers so I was
wondering how can we be aware of this
how can we come up with good ideas to
write even more declarative and even
more expressive and even more useful
code and the next question obviously is
how can we teach this how can we get a
community to the point we are using
iterators is so complex that you do not
question it
how can we use macros in a non-magical
sense because there are macros like Beck
the - did you see I used the Veck macro
no it doesn't really matter because it's
very expressive you know the types come
back the macros called back and to
expect it to generate the vector this
just works and so how can we actually
teach this so several approaches the
first one is through interactive
learning ya know it's the first this is
a ambitious one at first I'm so sorry
but I really like clip islands and I
know there was a lot of potential for
writing even more clip islands for
example there is one issue that happened
to be open by me about linting for loops
to suggest iterators for example this is
the code snippet that uses any could
have been a for loop with an if
statement and the return clip Dakota
Texas and tell you hey if you want to
write this in a more maybe
because you already okay yeah
and I hope you've got some inspiration
from it or at least some ideas on how to
and maybe do something differently in
your own code base or when you're
writing code thank you so much okay
thank you very much are the questions to
Pascal do you think there is a conflict
between declarative programming and the
performance in memory consumption if
understood correctly about performance
implications of using declarative
programming stance yes okay well it
depends on what you're doing of course
for example all these examples I showed
using 30 and using iterators were
actually faster because they did less
work but writing this code manually in
an imperative style would be very
tedious you can of course do it and
because on an assembly level everything
is imperative you can optimize every
program as an imperative level more
rigorously than you would be able to if
you have to trust some abstraction but I
believe especially in rust we've managed
to come up with some very good
abstractions that boil down to being
exact same assembly as an imperative
style for example using iterators
any more questions
[Music]
it seems to me that sometimes
declarative programming would almost
require some additional magic for
example when you did the take five and
collect you know it's sort of it does
say what to do and not how to do it but
it's not sort of obvious what the
resulting performance characteristics
might be because you don't know how it
accomplishes that task how do you
performance - no it's fine
the resulting performance you have to
measure it to be very very certain of
course but it happens to be the lazy to
write as a very fast so in this case you
will find that it's actually the same
performance is writing volume and of
course in the end you have to trust it
or you have to measure it I'd always err
on the side of measuring it but this
magic you're talking about to make this
fast is core trust see and we always
already using it so yeah any more
questions thank you for your talk you
mentioned that sometimes you look at
your old code and you wonder what you
did there what are the measure what do
you do then do you leave it like that or
do you start rewriting it or are you
putting memos for yourself for your
future self do this better next time
depends on whenever out to code I
started writing good commit messages at
some point I realized that I couldn't
remember what I wanted to do so I look
at my commit messages and say oh yeah
this what's what okay it works some of
the time but you're right basically I
have to read it I have to understand it
and have to guess and this is the same
for my own code as for everyone else's
making better guesses and being more
confident that these guesses about
expected behavior are what you wanted to
have is one of the advantages of having
declarative code in my opinions but also
Wright could commit messages all right
and thank you again Pascal